we have a voicemail number 219 to david
p let's take a listen to this voicemail
together you would think that
conservatives with know by now that
they've been conned by from but
apparently not because i visited with my
doctor today in politics are brought up
and he said man do you think the Trump
is really nailing these cabinet pics and
i thought he was joking but he clarified
it apparently he really thinks that
something going in the right direction
yeah i live in arkansas so i guess this
is just pretty much as brainwashes you
get I don't know how easy it is to find
a progressive doctor in Arkansas I
really don't but I would not go to as a
regular doctor a guy that I know to be a
right where I mean I my daughter is very
involved in democratic causes I know
that I know you know that his politics
quite well you know I know a lot of
surgeons for example surgeons tend to be
more conservative uh if I had to have
some kind of operation and then told
this is the guy who does the most
operations this is the woman who does
the most of this type of procedure I
would go to them uh and I wouldn't ask
about their politics but my regular
doctor I want my regular doctor to be
progressive yet when when you first
think about it I I was thinking why
would I care what my politics my doctor
are ya then you think of you know the
pharmaceutical industry yeah healthcare
industry and yeah it makes sense there
are political things in being someone's
primary care physician there's no doubt
about it but for me it's more just that
I I don't know my work is part of what
if you're treating me as a patient my
work is a big part of my life and
therefore I wouldn't want it to feel
like my work is somehow fundamentally at
odds with the philosophy of the person
who is in charge of serve overseeing my
healthy it's something like that that
that feels wrong certainly if you're
going to a psychologist you would want
that person to be liberal ah that will
that's a whole other interesting thing
and my girlfriend is in the Social Work
field and we've talked a lot about the
political orientation of mental health
professionals anyway story for another
day on the bonus show today my trip to
London I will tell you about it hats
excellent adventure road trip we will
hear about that and much more david
pakman.com slash membership
sign up and get instant access to the
bonus show you want a discount use the
coupon code I voted 17